so the question is who is
the next big star of the republican
party
well there was a phenomenal piece
written this week by a good good friend
of mine cliff schechter
writing for the daily beast the piece is
titled dan crenshaw is the trumpiest of
the wannabe new
trumps
and in the piece he talks about the fact
that sure we've got other conservatives
out there kind of you know hinting at
and testing the waters you got your
nikki haley's of course you got your ted
cruz maybe they're the ones to take up
the mantle of trumpism here in the u.s
and then of course you've got the really
wackier ones your marjorie taylor greens
and your boberts
and your gates's
but none of them cliff points out
have what dan crenshaw has
dan crenshaw
for the most part
is not as openly extreme as some of
those other individuals
he knows how to speak to an audience he
effectively has as cliff points out what
trump had
that charisma
coupled with of course shamelessness and
cruelty
but it's the charisma
it's his ability to play to an audience
much like donald trump did
that is what makes crenshaw so dangerous
and of course most likely the heir
apparent to donald trump's entire
political movement
you know crenshaw recently did an
interview where he called out the
performance artists
of the republican party
and he told us we know who they are he
didn't want to name any names he doesn't
want to make any waves because he's
smart i'll give him that he is smart
he's good at what he does
but it's pretty obvious that he is
talking about your marjorie taylor
greens and your lauren boberts the
people and madison cawthorns the people
who are out there just to get famous
they just want people to know their
names and as he pointed out correctly by
the way
they're not doing anything legislatively
okay they're not actually furthering the
conservative cause as he says
and his ability to call these people out
and seem
as he's calling them out like the
rational choice like the best
alternative
is what does make him so incredibly
dangerous as a potential candidate in
the future
and then of course
you have the performative side
crenshaw has something the rest of them
don't
he's got military credentials and as
cliff schechter points out again
he's got the battle wound
he's got the eye patch
and i'm not saying that to attack him
but that eye patch is a constant
reminder
that he served
that he went over there and fought the
fight
that these other conservatives only push
from behind their legislative desks
that makes a big
difference
with these republican candidates
somebody who can go out there and say oh
well you say you support the military
but i was actually in it i fought it
and i live with the ramifications of it
he's got that tough guy persona that
donald trump could only pretend to have
and of course you do have the
performance artist in him right
we've all seen the videos that crenshaws
point out uh put out excuse me himself
you know rappelling down from the
ceilings acting like some kind of
avenger slash secret agent guy this big
tough bravado
of only i can save this
which is kind of similar to what donald
trump actually said
when he first ran for president only i
can do this
and that's what crenshaw is putting out
there
he appeals to the trumpers
but he can act sane enough
because i do think to his credit i think
he is a sane person
but i think he knows when to turn on the
crazy and turn it off and that's what
separates him from the rest of the pack
that's what makes him different from a
marjorie taylor green
it's what makes him different from a ted
cruz because ted cruz has gone full
blown into all of this he doesn't know
who he is
but crenshaw
can turn it on and turn it off like that
and as cliff points out
that's something that makes him
incredibly valuable
to the conservative movement and of
course makes him incredibly scary
as a potential republican candidate in
the future
i'm farin cousins follow me on youtube
at youtube.com the ring of fire and
youtube.com fair and balanced i'm across
social media platforms twitter facebook
instagram at fair and balanced
you're watching the david pakman show
we'll be right back with more